people often ask me why don't I do face
scans well there are two important
reasons for that one being the fact that
I don't like it when people play
rollercoaster 3 with face cams obviously
since nobody really does this and with
good reasons because it's not really a
game like the games that PewDiePie would
play it's not like slender where you
actually watch the video to see the
reaction of the girl doing it roller
coaster tycoon 3 is a very passive game
in that sense you don't really do
anything except for build things I don't
think there's really a lot of facial
expression stuff going on for that and
honestly nobody's really done videos on
Veronica's taken 3 with face cam before
and now you can say wait pieces of
prestige did it but those were live
streams that he uploaded as videos onto
YouTube so it doesn't really count in
that sense at least that's what I'd say
and there was there's a second reason I
kind of forgot that oh wait yeah it's
the fact that I am very awkward very
kind of oh c'mon yeah probably in our
face cams oh at least I felt like that
no little bit shy so that's why but
people kept requesting it so I was like
I might as well try its this is a
terrible idea
okay I didn't even see the point of this
but I'm doing it because peer pressure
and all that so this building this
building is not that great honestly I
know I say that about my own things too
much but I actually like the other part
of that like the flying coaster is
actually really cool but these bigger
buildings just don't kind of work out I
don't know why and of course I still
need to do foliage but that's something
I'm not really looking forward to
because way bears large rocks and that's
that always crashes on me so I am kind
of in a situation right now where I
don't really feel like doing all of
these things I don't know if that makes
sense I hope it does but at least I can
out windows through this building is
something something boring on you know
it's time to do some of the boring stuff
that I just need to do anyway so might
as well do it right now and you can tell
that the lag is absolutely
ridiculous yeah I still need to buy a
new PC really really badly this one is
actually I'm using a laptop and it sucks
and the funny thing is actually I kind
of have you know money right now I just
didn't get to ordering the parts of my
PC yet also I'm gonna try and build it
myself with pieces that Danny sent me so
Thank You Danny for that but I'm
probably gonna fail miserably of that so
that's gonna be good fun oh well and I'm
actually looking forward to getting
better graphics and a faster PC because
my like is absolutely absolutely
ridiculous I remember why I did that
tutorial on advanced era painting and I
was like okay excuse me for the lag and
there was nothing in my Park so
obviously people were like how do you
have like there's nothing in your Park
all right yeah that's kind of how shitty
my laptop is so they have that and I
knew this is actually a good idea might
add a third reason why I shouldn't do
facecam stuff on videos it's the same
reason I I kind of did base camp
in streams already and Skype calls and
all that and the only problem with that
is is that it takes away the
concentration on roller-coaster country
and moves it to something else that it's
not really that important so instead of
actually focusing on getting the best
building over here I'm still focusing on
delivering commentary and I don't know
if that's a great idea
oh well this is some simple stuff I
guess I need to kind of plan my simple
things for episodes with Skype because
I'm probably gonna do that again because
people keep questioning that for some
reason so might as well the only thing
is I kind of depends on whoever is on
skype and whether there's actually good
fun times and whether I don't forget
recording because awful quick I forget
things all the time
hmm okay yeah others look this looks
decent see the only problem that I have
with this building is it is a bit square
maybe just maybe just maybe I should
just go crazy on this thing
maybe I should actually try adding a
random Terezin [ __ ] that would actually
be a good idea for episode like this
okay that's also a good idea experiment
just random experimentation with things
because that's the problem that I have
with time lapses I'm very much afraid of
experimenting with stuff when I'm making
time lapses simply because I'm afraid
that the time lapse will just come out
as something where I build and delete
and build and delete and forever
basically that I hope my microphone is
not so closed in my mind if this had set
[ __ ] sucks I know if this is good
okay that's gonna be terrible in the
audio readout I'm sorry for that okay
let's see we need some some of that
Ralphie's goodness I'm probably looking
like a zombie right now at my screen
that's how I play all the coasts taken
three all the time I think that's how
everybody plays well the coast taken
three honestly although all the streams
that I've seen so far with people doing
face cams are pretty much with that
facial expression of playing roller
coaster core 3 and yeah okay medieval
I'm really glad though that I removed
the spooky theme because is that is that
even called spook I think it is gosh I
can't even say the word spooky without
all of the ironic meanings attached to
it okay that's too small just our one
bit yeah it's how one is bigger
I know if this is a good location for
this kind of thing but why is what's
right I mean it worked good it worked
well on the other side of the place or
not why not try it over here I guess and
then of course we need that saddle over
there you know head and a nice little
supplier very inspiring okay sorry I
won't do that again and so you know
let's just go for the double window
across the sky
sorry okay yeah yeah so first part of
the set I really wish there was actually
a third part of this I thought about
making that myself but it would be too
much effort and when it comes to meat
and building custom scenery sets I never
come around finishing them and it also
makes me feel like a dick because I make
all these things but I don't release
them but it's not because I don't want
to release them it's just because I'm
afraid to release them when they're not
really good but in any case if you want
to pick up all of my unreleased custom
scenery sets they're in my style theme
follow on the About section of my
YouTube page so that kind of makes me
feel okay about it again okay small
Tower there's always room for some small
towers honestly and I feel like this
would be a good location especially
because there's no windows over there
and stuff like that um the texture is a
bit stupid though it's the only problem
that I'm having with this however I
might mess with this some more um let's
see maybe Station Tim's castle things
would actually work out get over here
castle things and there's a big arc in
this somewhere there we go
felt like maybe this could do something
but hmmm well I was actually somewhat
cool takes out the symmetry of
everything and screws symmetry really
for this park at least normally I'm all
for symmetry I have OCD to the max but
for this I'm making an exception maybe
you could maybe we could actually have
some battlements on top of this or yeah
that's what once that's what they're
called and some of those other fancy
things it's not like decent it actually
does Wow
I might actually be able to pull this
off as weird as it is it is somewhat
unique and it takes the
it does bring in the media medieval
elements of this park again which is
probably a good idea okay I'm just gonna
see you where where this is gonna go and
by that I mean that I am building random
things that's how I work yeah I know
know if it's great idea sometimes it
results in awesomeness sometimes it
results in awfulness but I build random
things they random but I never
have a plan beforehand though honestly I
don't think um what's his name again
and one never mind hmm
not plenty of people who do things
without planning ha
plenty okay sorry I am I'm terrible when
it comes to puns I mean I'm good at them
but they're always terrible like that I
would probably make a great dad hmm
yeah that actually looks pretty cool get
that nice little gates kind of idea
oh no oh wait I should watch out okay
don't be a zombie just sit up straight
and don't do weird things okay I swear
when when I'm not paying attention to it
I'm gonna sit here drooling and just
looking at rollercoaster country like
this and that's gonna be a terrible idea
hmm
need some small-town windows is it
that's all I have really well that looks
pretty cool I do
must just kind of be with the rest of
the building like it looks cool but it
needs some more castle influences if it
really wants to if I really want to pull
this off well so don't really know what
to put that so that's kind of hard and
fingers any room in here
well there is room actually beautiful I
could even play I could play something
on the side um let's see but I can't
decide when I could play something on
the side but I can't decide oh my god I
mean I'm gonna kill myself after this so
let's see like obviously I've got these
boxes over here which it's just there
because there's nothing else to place
over there so might as well try and get
a tower in there but then again that
corner is kind of the
one corner that you don't really see oh
well I'm just gonna go for it and I
think I'm just gonna use the Oh God
hitboxes they're the worst thing why why
are the hitboxes that big there's no
point to that really okay that's
probably the only thing that I hate
about the Alpine SAS and I think catfish
Cove as it as well he ridiculously
launched hitboxes Oh God in before this
is the overused tower that everybody
over uses so it doesn't look good
anymore which is partly right however
hmm I don't know about that it looks
cool though it looks decent but I don't
think it really fits in here hmm but I
didn't remove those windows and I don't
want to replace them so I'm gonna have
to find something else to do well maybe
I could just lower it honestly like make
it a tower that doesn't stick out quite
as much and thankfully the roof has the
same color so there's might actually
work out okay the back of the building
is not interesting at all but it doesn't
have to be hmm you know this actually
works decent good enough for me at least
now of course I do want to add a small
Tower to that because tower Romania nice
little small tower oh god the lag lag is
absolutely ridiculous and I am pretty
sure that this part with the Sun had
that interesting little porch thing
there we go okay now I need to be
careful get that placement right oh yeah
that's good it's in the weather vane of
the the little tower but who gives a
[ __ ]
a decent could be better but it's decent
need some more castle things in here
yeah definitely oh yeah one other thing
I should still get is a new microphone
or at least a microphone because I don't
have any I'm using I'm still using this
crappy hat sir
because ground loop and I need to keep
my hand on my laptop because ground loop
and it's really stupid because ground
loop this thing might actually work
honestly like getting some small tower
action over there it might actually be
cool but it looks weird
hmmm yeah it does look weird yeah that's
not saying no go hmmm I do want
something over there though or at least
just a little bit of medieval stuff a
wee I forgot I still have this little
area I can play something over here um
let's see I don't think there's really
anything that works well in this part of
this set maybe on some of these dormers
no not really
especially not because this is just one
small roof it's not really anything well
we have the fence Tower okay now we go
thank you placement for being annoying
but that just looks awkward
that looks very awkward
see I need to place something over there
and that actually doesn't like that
awkward I think I have an idea I think I
have an idea
let's see get that get that for brick
get that for break lays that brick yeah
over there that'll work
but that heights yeah I should work why
did why didn't I turn the grid on I'm so
stupid
okay that doesn't work we need to move
this over there put it there and see if
I can make something out of this somehow
I've no clue with this but I just want
to try it that's probably a bit too high
hmm then again making it lower probably
suck as well a cone just gonna go for it
I kind of want to break the just the
simple shape of the building I want to
make it more over-the-top more like the
rest of the park this building wasn't
that bad but I feel like what was wrong
with it was the fact that it was
realistic and we need to get rid of that
realistic nurse and that modest nurse
and just go over the top and crazy on it
okay let's see if I can press control
while holding my hand on my laptop at
the same time oh that works I'm one of
those battlements the battlements look
kind of derp yeah that kind of dirt hmm
well maybe I should add something else
to the side really hmm
come on get that placement right thank
you very much cadets you hmm
felt like maybe I could add a little
worn this side yeah I'm just gonna try
it so get some more of that beautiful
beautiful 4-h
all I just realized I haven't done too
much with diagonals in this park should
try that as well if I can and glitchy
glitchy glitch we need to get rid of
that I'm plenty of time left this is
already a long episode but who cares
really I don't think anybody cares
except for Sony Vegas it's gonna kind of
struggle with this but whatever and this
time I might just be too small but my
eyes what go for it yeah that's decent
that's what this always also does this
extra part also kind of allows me to add
more towers to this I like this idea
pretty cool it's gonna be a facade of
towers because everybody loves towers
okay let's see I guess that's what's so
amazing about medieval style and also
the fact that it gets overused medieval
is kind of an overused theme just
because it's like okay
do you have it built the shape of the
building doesn't even matter that much
as long as you just spam towers it's
gonna look decent anyway okay now this
is gonna be hard because I don't want to
add weird towers to this little part but
I do want to add something I want to
leave it just bare like this does this
have a floor piece it does not but it
has the bridge piece as long as this
thing doesn't okay
does go through that well that's a shame
hmm in that case I don't think there's
anything to use a nuts at so I'm gonna
have to use the floors from this set
come on mate I don't even know okay
there we go they're probably a bit too
lights though that's the only thing that
I don't like about these textures is
they're kind of light oh well you're not
gonna see the floor of that anyway so it
doesn't really matter where this creates
a very nice look from this side that's
very nice cool like that also my room I
know I know my room is terrible sorry
for that sorry about that why do I keep
saying that mm-hmm yeah I could use
these things but that's stupid don't
know don't even really know what to do
with them but I might try actually just
try to add some cool stuff just try it's
all right except these columns aren't
going to work anymore now
yeah it's a bit too low like if it
weren't this heights it would actually
work hmm I guess this is okay why not
it's probably a bit weird honestly no
well I'm just gonna go for it more
detail more detail is always good when
it comes to medieval pikes this column
is also really cool but it's kind of you
know if this is a great idea it's gonna
be a column fest right now yeah that's
too over the top maybe a column on that
side and a little medieval tower on this
side maybe that'll work out I might also
use more columns to support the columns
though that also looks weird yeah I'm
just gonna use column 2h I wish there
was actually a column for H part for
this I didn't even know if this is the
right use to use this part but I always
find that using custom scenery sets for
things that you're not supposed to use
them for actually is the best thing you
can do oh right I forgot about this
little Tower this cute Tower I love this
thing like honestly I might as well at
that and then just put zero G's thing on
this side because zero-g has that sexy
sexy thing I mean not 0g I keep giving
zero-g credit for the things in this set
but it's made quite station Jim hmm okay
I kind of want to finish this right now
but I have to go to school a couple
minutes
oh god my planning is the worst thing
ever oh there we go
those pillars thank you very much
and danke Shoen that's pretty cool
it's a bit thin though compared to all
the other things on the building hmm I
don't know if I like that I don't know
if I like that
perhaps it's actually better to use a
set that I'm not supposed to use in this
case that being that's efteling set
which is in Dutch because I don't know
why but it's kind of mean I don't know
why people do that like come on we're an
international community don't make SATs
in a language that not everybody speaks
especially not if there aren't any
thumbnails
okay the contrast with that the Brix is
too big hmm I actually don't really know
what to do with this point I am kind of
in a pickle right here I think I'm just
gonna go with sewage ease things after
all yeah
and this time I said 0g Sphinx that's
the name of the set so it doesn't really
matter I didn't go search it credit
though Sara G is still awesome right and
I can remove this thing at this point
because it's just ugly hmm hmm it's
decent
but it's not really that good oh well
let's see what happens if I add windows
mmm this Sat doesn't have good windows
time to go back to zero G's things we
need that real og steampunk stuff
gorgeous love it
actually is actually pretty cool now I'm
looking at this from a distance because
I'm like a painter roller coaster in
three years arts it's an amazing game
it's total arts definitely yeah it's not
that bad
I can imagine that when I add a couple
more details to this is actually going
to look pretty cool a lot better than
the station I used to have though it
does need some work still but at this
point I feel like I've done enough
mainly because it's almost time
so that was my weird little face cam
session which is the first time I've
ever done this so sorry if this was
weird and awkward in a sense that's just
me so yeah thanks for watching i'm gonna
play pokemon and go [ __ ] animal on my
gameboy advanced swear this best thing
ever so thanks for watching and bye